[Musique]
gagnon débat sur france 24 il ya tout
juste trois mois à la surprise générale
la dîmière poutine lancé son opération
spéciale en ukraine il pensait conquérir
rapidement kiev et renverser le
gouvernement trois mois plus tard la
guerre est loin d'être terminée moscou
concentre ses forces dans le donbass la
russie s'est dit déterminé à atteindre
tous ces objectifs
les ukrainiens résiste l'occident est
unis au sein de l'otan et ed
militairement kiev alors après 90 jours
de combats intenses on va tenter ce soir
de faire un premier bilan quels sont les
enseignements de ces trois mois de
guerre cette guerre va-t-elle durer où
en est la résistance des ukrainiens dans
le donbass justement quels sont les
espoirs d'une paix quel impact sur la
sécurité en europe trois mois de guerre
à quand la fin on en débat avec mes
invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes
côtés jean maurice ripert bonsoir
bienvenue à vous rend pas ça dort de
france ancien ambassadeur de france en
russie en chine et à l'onu en face de
vous régis genté bonsoir correspondant
rfi et france 24 basée à tbilissi
coauteur avec stéphane sur en de
volodymyr et l'ins qui dans la tête d'un
héros et ça vient de paraître chez
robert laffont bienvenue également nous
avons également avec tous jean françois
colossimo bonsoir à vous au directeur
général des éditions du cerf et puis
bien sûr historien et puis à part skate
de rouen adrien 2 juin bonsoir rédacteur
à la revue conflit hauteur je cite votre
livre de la france atlantiste ou le
naufrage de la diplomatie et c'est aux
éditions du cerf merci d'être avec toi
et puis en haut rang avec nous en duplex
de kiev cyril payen grand reporter
france24 envoyé spécial bonsoir avoue
cyril avant de vous retrouver d'ailleurs
cyril on va je vous propose de regarder
un résumé de ces trois mois de guerre
avec gilles boiteau
le 24 février 2022 le monde se réveille
stupéfait devant le fracas des bombes en
europe les chars de moscou viennent de
pénétrer par centaines sur le territoire
ukrainien vladimir poutine dit vouloir
défendre les républiques séparatistes du
dombass reconnu indépendante
j'ai pris la décision de lancer une
opération militaire
mais les forces russes ne se cantonne
pas à l'est du pays le kremlin multiplie
les fronts il prend le contrôle de zone
au nord de kiev mais est très vite
confronté à la pugnacité de la
résistance ukrainienne une résistance
incarné par un homme
il ya beaucoup de fausses informations
sur internet en ce moment en disant à
notre armée de déposer les armes et
qu'une évacuation est en cours et bien
moi je suis là
la loi martiale est instaurée tous les
hommes de 18 à 60 ans sont appelés à se
battre pour la plupart des autres c'est
l'exode forcé au 20 mars 10 millions
d'ukrainiens ont quitté leur foyer selon
l'onu une première en europe depuis la
seconde guerre mondiale pour sauver la
capitale ailleurs pin les ukrainiens
détruites même ce pont qui devient le
symbole de la résistance à kharkiv la
deuxième plus grande ville du pays il
repousse petit à petit les forces russes
après des semaines de bombardements les
ukrainiens oblige même les troupes
adverses a reculé près de la frontière
après un mois de combat impossible pour
les russes de prendre la capitale les
forces de moscou se recentre donc sur le
dombass et sur la ville de marioupol
pilonnaient depuis le début de la guerre
est détruite à 90% elle tombe aux mains
russe le 21 avril à l'exception du site
métallurgique d'azov talent depuis les
sous sols de la syrie des centaines de
soldats du chrétien résiste aux 86e
jours de guerre ils finissent par se
rendre à l'armée russe une armée russe
accusé de crimes de guerre avec son
repli du nord de kiev fin mars elle
laisse derrière elle les horreurs des
massacres de civils dans les rues de
boudhha les images de dizaines de
cadavres d'habitants exécuté choc le
monde entier lundi le premier soldat
russe jugée en ukraine pour crimes de
guerre
a été reconnu coupable et condamné à la
prison à perpétuité pour le meurtre d'un
civil
cyril cyril payen puisque vous êtes à
kiev on sait vous avez retrouvé des
combattants que vous aviez suivi il ya
quelques semaines dans quel état
d'esprit les avez vous retrouvé ses
soldats donc après à trois mois de début
de conflit
mais côté ils sont à l'image très
clairement de cet entre-deux guerres je
dirais qu'on se trouve ici dans l'ouest
de l'ukraine et puis dans la capitale où
se trouve d'ailleurs si là il la nuit va
tomber mais j'imagine que vous pouvez
avoir une idée de cette normalité ou en
tout cas tentative de normalisation
de vie que veulent reprendre résolument
c'est très très clair et c'est la grande
différence avec il ya deux mois
reprendre la vie sociale économique ici
à à kiev l'état dans lequel sont ces
volontaires qui pour la plupart dans ces
zones de résistances importantes qui
sont certainement la clé de la
résistance finale à l'assaut des unités
russes sur kiev tout dégoûté au début de
la guerre de c'est donc de cesser c'est
mobilisation de défense de taille du
territoire pardon sont dans un état qui
est en fait à l'image de ces de ces
régions donc je parle de ce tome elle
boude chaliapine dont on parlait dans ce
sujet mais également comme on a sillonné
depuis trois jours avec mohammad fara tu
es bien toute cette partie ouest qui va
jusqu'à la frontière bien relu ce biais
bien le russe et qui a marqué le premier
coup de butoir de l'état-major russe
vers vers la l'ukraine avec cette guerre
éclair qui aurait dû théoriquement durer
trois jours pour prendre kiev donc on
paie au prix fort même si on a un
sentiment encore une fois d'après guerre
de volonté de passer de 7,7 ce sentiment
de résistance farouche qui a surpris
tout le monde à une forme de résilience
ici il ya une inflation galopante il n'y
a pas d'essence il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup de pénurie et on sait que la
guerre fait rage à 500 km de là où se
trouve on tente de tourner la page mais
c'est vrai que les stigmates de cette
guerre dont 7,7 forme d'après guerre que
l'on vit ici sont absolument effroyable
effroyable qui glace le sang c'est à
dire que même les villes les villages
sont détruits ou partiellement détruits
nous avons parcouru des zones qui ont
été occupées pendant plus d'un mois par
différentes vagues de régime en russe et
l'aller les témoignages sont absolument
horrible puisqu'on parle on parle de
deux viols par centaines on parle d'
exactions évidemment de disparitions de
mineurs de jeunes garçons dont on nous a
dit et qu'il s'agissait de trophées dont
on a aucune idée d'où ils sont venus
donc c'est ça aussi cette page qui se
tourne mais qui laisse entrevoir sans
doute ce qui se passe actuellement au
moment on parle dans tout l'est c'est à
dire dans le donbass dans une partie de
la crimée c'est à dire des crimes de
guerre dont évidemment c'est d'actualité
puisque l'ukraine ne part pas de temps
il y a eu vous l'avez dit évidemment ce
premier soldat russe qui a été condamnée
jugés puis condamnés extrêmement
rapidement c'est assez inédit d'ailleurs
d'aller aussi vite mais on sent bien
qu'ici c'est une véritable barbarie
systématique qui a été établi dans les
zones occupées et qu'on ne fait que
commencer
de bien réaliser l'ampleur de l'horreur
qu'ont vécu les habitants sous
l'occupation russe jean françois
colosimo plus que vous êtes l'historien
de ce plateau sur les enseignements ça
serait intéressant de démarrer justement
par ce qui nous a surpris d'avoir cette
attaque de poutine personne ne
l'attendait le 24 février il pensait lui
qu'il allait ce que disait bien sûr
cyril prendre kiev en trois jours il a
échoué il s'est rabattu dans le donbass
est ce qu'il y avait eu est ce qu'il ya
eu une surestimation d'abord par
vladimir poutine de la puissance de son
armée et est-ce qu'aujourd'hui faire la
grande russie des nazis fier l'ukraine
s'est toujours son objectif les buts de
guerre de lanières poutine n'ont pas
cessé de deux variés effectivement on
est parti sur une opération spéciale qui
avait pour but de renverser zelensky
parce qu'ils s'attendaient probablement
à ce que les ukrainiens particulièrement
ceux de l'est russophone et orthodoxes
en quelque sorte en dos la cause de
moscou ça n'est pas arrivé à partir de
ce moment là on a eu toute une série de
discours absolue au discours de raisons
humanitaires sauver ces populations de
l'est qui aurait été menacé de génocide
ce qui est évidemment faux ensuite on a
eu vingt dix cours de légitime défense
la russie était encerclée l'otan allait
fondre sur la russie fait donc la
défendre ensuite on a eu un discours
quasiment civilisationnel il fallait
avait des défis et l'ukraine réédition
de la seconde guerre mondiale puis on a
eu un discours pré génocidaire il
fallait des ukrainiens et les ukrainiens
et à la fin on a eu un discours mais
deux guerres totales l'ennemi c'est
l'occident n'est ce pas et tout ça pour
essayer de fédérer et vise effectivement
l'hémisphère sud souvent mécontents de
l'occident ce qui n'est pas arrivé à
faire il n'a pas rallié à les gens à sa
guerre mais probablement clame dans
l'hémisphère sud il y a des gens qui ont
l'impression que lui aussi fait une
guerre par délégation et donc de ce
point de vue là on a eu une montée aux
extrêmes et aujourd'hui effectivement le
plus surprenant parce que pourquoi si la
guerre on pensait qu'elle pouvait avoir
lieu on pensait qu'elle n'aurait pas
lieu parce qu'il n'y avait aucun intérêt
et étaient tous ces intérêts ont été des
trompes et regarder la suède et la
finlande qui portent vais revenir à la
porte de l'otan régis jantes et l'autre
surprise c'est bien sûr la résistance
des ukrainiens parce que là aussi
finalement on ne l'attendait pas ces
soldats finalement on apprend qu'ils
étaient déjà entraîné discrètement par
les occidentaux c'est ce que le wall
street journal révèle aujourd'hui qui
affirme que dix mille militaires
d'ukrainiens avaient reçu chaque année
depuis 2014 une formation dans un état
membre de l'otan mais c'était une
surprise véritablement 7 cette
résistance vous qui avez écrit ce livre
survoler diverses des inscrits whissell
ça l'était certainement même si on a on
a pu voir ces dernières années pas
simplement parce qu'ils ont été en
partie entraîné par l'occident mais
parce que c'est un pays qui est aussi
dans une sorte de formation de son état
nation qu'on observe depuis très
longtemps à vrai dire ça fait deux
siècles ça dure c'est quelque chose qui
est très enracinée qui s'est
véritablement accélérer après 2014 c'est
la même guerre concordat aujourd'hui qui
a commencé avec l'invasion de l'ukraine
à ce moment-là et une armée qui était
complètement déliquescente à l'époque il
faut s'en souvenir mais véritablement
incapable d'affronter la russie et puis
et puis petit à petit après 2014 après
cette agression et bien qu'ils étaient
remises sur pied qui s'est entraînée par
elle même avec l'aide des occidentaux
aussi et puis dans un contexte plus
général d'un pays qui s'unit les
populations de l'est de l'ukraine qui
sont pas toutes russophone c'est surtout
les villes qui sont russophones les
villages sont encore très souvent
l'ukraine aux folles il faut faire
attention à cette distinction et à vrai
dire la question n'existe pas souvent
pour les ukrainiens ce qui compte c'est
dans quel pays on veut vivre est ce
qu'il y aura l'état de droit est ce
qu'on sera riche est ce qu'on sera
pauvre et c'est ce qui fait que petit à
petit ces populations ont beaucoup
changé moi quand j'allais dans le
donbass en 2014 pour vous pour rfi je me
souviens très bien quand à la sortie de
la partie occupée je rencontrais des
vides dans des villes des populations à
80% pro-russe et ça a changé au fil des
ans jusqu'à aujourd'hui il a résultat
qu'on observe avec cette figure de
volodymyr zelensky puisque vous avez
écrit un livre sur lui qui incarne qui
avait très vite incarner cette nation
ukrainienne c'est le bon mot sans doute
il incarne lui-même son pedigree sociaux
social culturel offre est plutôt
quelqu'un du appartenant aux mondes
russie par les mâles ukrainien il ya
quelques années il parle russe le marché
pour ses productions lorsqu'il était
comédien était en russie il est né à
crivoï rod comme on dit en russe une
ville russophone industrielle de l'est
l'ukraine mais en fait il a accompagné
effectivement le mouvement de de son
pays vers une sorte d'indépendance
d'émancipation vis-à-vis de la russie
pour choisir une vie à l'ukrainienne si
j'ose dire vaguement inspiré des
cosaques
interdire
aspirant à devenir plus proche de
l'europe etc
jean maurice ripert justement ces trois
mois de guerre puisque on fait le bilan
elle montre est ce qu'elle montre qu'il
n'ya plus de guerre courte
moi je voudrais quand même d'abord
revenir sur ce que dit rebondissez mais
monsieur connaissez je vais vous
répondre je suis d'accord sur tout ce
qu'il a dit sauf que le combat contre la
démocratie les droits de l'homme je
pense que c'était au coeur déjà de ce
que vladimir poutine voulait faire voilà
longtemps moqué travailler en russie
qu'il a décidé de rejoindre le combat
des chinois notamment contre la
démocratie elle est donc vous n'était
pas très surpris qu'il attaque j'étais
surpris je n'étais pas surpris qu'il
s'en prenne à l'ukraine je reconnais que
j'ai été surpris parce que je pensais
que c'était une erreur et que je lui ai
prêté une rationalité que manifestement
il n'avait déjà plus la deuxième chose
excusez moi de rappeler ça mais je crois
que c'est important c'est ce qu'a dit
votre reporter cette guerre est une
boucherie les nations unies estiment à
plus de cinquante mille le nombre de
morts civils
l'embout de soi-même ukrainienne a sorti
ce matin des documents il faudra aller
vérifier qu'ils montrent que le viol a
été usée utilisé comme arme de guerre
systématiques contre des enfants voire
contre des bébés c'est une guerre atroce
que vladimir poutine a imposé au peuple
ukrainien il veut la destruction de
l'ukraine pardon d'avoir commencer par
cela mais je crois qu'il faut quand même
bien savoir de quoi on parle est ce que
cette guerre peut être courte oui ou
est-ce que c'est terminé il n'y aura
plus de guerre courte qu'elle monte j'ai
entendu un des nombreux généraux qui
fréquentent les plateaux dire quelque
chose qui m'a paru très juste elle
prouve cette guerre une fois de plus
qu'on ne peut plus gagner les guerres de
manière militaire les russes n'ont pas
gagné donc ils ont perdu aujourd'hui la
guerre doit être totale sur tous les
plans économiques cyber agricole tout ce
que vous voudrez les russes ont déjà
perdu cette guerre ça ne veut pas dire
que sur le terrain les russes ne vont
pas rester je crains qu'il reste un
certain temps dans les positions qu'ils
ont occupé jusqu'à présent adrien théaux
à votre justement votre réaction sur ces
trois mois de guerre ce que ça signifie
effectivement qu'il n'y aura plus de
guerre courte vous pouvez rebondir sur
ce que vient de dire jean maurice ripert
oui on a tous été un peu surpris faut
reconnaître en france et que l'armée
russe au début elle est rentrée dans
kiev allait faire tomber ce régime
bien que certains observateurs dont
j'étais disait qu' il y avait un risque
finalement d'enlisement de l'armée russe
une fois qu'elle serait rentré en
ukraine finalement on est revenu un
conflit assez classique de haute
intensité pas du tout un conflit
de type contre insurrectionnelle comme
moi même je l'envisageais et de l'est
russie notamment ont eu à mon avis
l'habileté tactique de se retirer de
quête de comprendre en fait ils
n'arriveraient pas à renverser et
apprendre kiev et donc à réduire le
feront finalement sur la partie est ce
qui au début parisella
j'ai à dire la solution la plus simple
pour les russes et que tout le monde
avait un peu envisagé c'est à dire juste
aux conquêtes dunant basse avec un crime
et qui seraient rattachés
territorialement et non plus pas
seulement par le détroit de kertch à la
russie et ses skis on est en train de
constater sur le terrain c'est-à-dire
des conquêtes relativement limité
le banc basse la région et personnes et
la région de milito paul avec une russie
qui renonce finalement et là
effectivement pour parler donc certaines
défaites qu'ils renoncent à odessa qui
renonce finalement à bloquer la mer
noire à l'ukraine
j'ai chanté sur les pertes de part et
d'autre dans ce conflit les deux côtés
on entend des chiffres très différent
parce qu'en fait on sait qu'il ya de
quoi aussi une guerre de l'information
par les deux guerres totales de guerre
l'undd longue pardon les français disent
que les ukrainiens ont perdu 15 mille
hommes dont une vingtaine de généraux
soit autant que du côté russe s'est
aussi les chiffres que vous avez très
peu de chiffres et je crois même que le
nombre de morts côté ukrainien est un
secret d'état c'est vraiment très
difficile chaque les ong internationales
par exemple nous ramena n'ont même pas
accès par exemple aux blessés ils
peuvent pas les voir peuvent pas aussi
évaluer le type de blessure dont il
souffre et c'est le côté russe on en
sait un tout petit peu plus il ya eu
quelques accidents de publication il ya
à peu près un mois et demi par exemple
sur ria novosti un site officiel pendant
quelques minutes par accident ou pas on
a eu une liste un bilan on était déjà à
quelque chose comme 15000 morts qu il ya
un bon mois et demi côté russe côté
russe donc on peut imaginer
qu'aujourd'hui on est aisément à au delà
des vingt ou vingt-cinq mille mais c'est
de la pure spéculation et faire lui-même
il faut garder le secret on sent qu'il
faut surtout pas divulguer le nombre
pourquoi
parce que parce que ça démoralise les
troupes parce que on donne de l'espoir à
son adversaire jean françois copé six
morts oui je pense que les pertes russes
sont considérables en matériel on sait
en sommes probablement
vraiment énorme dans le sens où là où
nous sommes d'accord
dire que j'ai expliqué que c'étaient les
scada dans les indications mais
l'intéressé l'occident l'ennemi cette
représentation démocratie et droits
l'homme poutine ne compte pas il ne
compte pas des vies ukrainienne mais il
ne compte pas les virus pas plus ça
c'est ce qu'il faut bien comprendre et
peut être que là on n'a pas été attentif
c'est le bouclage complet de la russie
du point de vue de l'information et du
point de l'opposition qui déjà était
très très résiduel qui a précédé ont
fait de manière accélérée l'entrée dans
le conflit donc poutine mènent deux
guerres et mène une guerre en ukraine et
en russie il mène aussi une guerre
contre ce qui pourrait s'opposer à son
pouvoir voyez ce front là il faut pas
non plus le minorer ce qui explique que
la population russe soit captive d'une
fausse information permanente et plus
pour conclure dans cette fausse
information on ne va pas annoncer des
pertes considérables au contraire
d'ailleurs il est très ennuyé de ne pas
réussir son opération est en fait du
coup il ya eu un climat de psychose qui
est étendu à toute la population russe
c'est que demain ça va être l'apocalypse
et que le monde entier veut la mort des
russes alors que lui est en train de
vouloir effectivement les parfaitement
d'accord l'anéantissement de l'ukraine
selon elle se réfère donc je suis je
partage totalement cette analyse et il
faut rappeler que l'objectif premier
d'un dictateur c'est de rester au
pouvoir l'objectif premier de vladimir
poutine et de son clan c'est de rester
au pouvoir hilale souvenir lui aussi de
l'impact qu'ont eu sur la population
russe et notamment sur les mers russe le
retour des corps d'afghanistan de
tchétchénie de syrie il ne veut pas que
les corps russes reviennent dans les
familles c'est pour ça qu'il a engagée
d'abord d'aider le groupe wagner des
mercenaires tchétchènes des mercenaires
syrien et cetera et cetera il a peur de
la réaction des des russes les russes ne
veulent pas la guerre les russes ne
voulait pas de la guerre c'est pour ça
aussi qu'il n'a jamais employé le mot de
guerre il fallait cacher la réalité vous
avez vu ces soldats ce soldat qui a été
car reconnu avoir été coupable
d'assassinats de civils il a dit quand
je suis parti en ukraine je ne savais
pas où envoyer
maintenant qu'on a parlé un peu des
leçons qu'on n'a pu tirer depuis ces
trois mois on va tenté d'évoquer
l'avenir et pour cela on va d'abord
écouté
volodymyr zelensky c'était hier davos il
évoque la menace le président ukrainien
cette menace russe dont vous voulez vous
venez de parler jean maurice ripert on
écoute
disent pas qu'ils corrigent sipan au
bâton à switcher
nous sommes à un tournant un moment qui
déterminera si c'est la force brutale
qui dominera le monde cette force
brutale n'est pas intéressé par nos
réunions il n'y aura plus de réunions
comme d'hab aussi cette force
l'emportent cette force brutale ne
cherche qu'à soumettre ceux qui lui
résistent elles ne discute pas elle tu
sais ce que la russie est en train de
faire en ce moment même en ukraine comme
cyril cyril payen à kiev il évoque un
tournant finalement vous le dit me raser
linski un tournant après ces trois mois
de guerre est ce que vous avez
l'impression sur le terrain qu'on nous
sommes effectivement une croisée des
chemins
ce qui est certain c'est que évidemment
le troisième mois c'était l'entrée dans
le quatrième mois à partir de demain
c'est l'heure des bilans on est
certainement dans un entre deux en tout
cas ce qui est absolument certain c'est
que personne n'a gagné la guerre
certainement pas l'état-major russe
alors là on en est absolument persuadé
mais les ukrainiens ne l'ont pas gagné
non plus et c'est là aussi où on était
dans une posture essentiellement
défensive je parle de l'état-major
ukrainien je parle de des forces de
défense ukrainienne pendant de longues
semaines on l'a vu sur la grande la
seconde grandes offensives menées par
l'armée russe ural suractif kharkiv
l'oblast de karkhiv là la grande zone
administrative de kharkiv qui se trouve
à l'est de kiev est là aussi
cet échec ce demi échec à moitié avoué
et puis cette nouvelle posture
stratégique ukrainienne de
contre-offensive village par village où
on semble s'installer cette nouvelle
tactique alors est-ce qu'on va justement
tactiquement aller vers l'offensive
c'est évidemment ce que appellent de
leurs voeux beaucoup de d'ukrainiens qui
ne veulent pas faire une redite de 2014
c'est-à-dire qu'on restera un statu quo
et que finalement dit nous distille
d'ailleurs et bien vladimir outin si on
mettait enfin fin à la guerre en l'état
est bien dans deux ans trois ans
peut-être avant va réattaquer donc il y
a une volonté assez général d'en
découdre d'aller un peu jusqu'au bout et
c'est pour ça que là aussi la ligne de
partage qui sépare dans la communauté
internationale les nations qui sont
résolument engagés belliciste je pense
bien évidemment à washington qui a
décidé de se mettre en avant de 40
milliards de dollars débloqué récemment
ce n'est pas le premier paquet d'argent
qui a été débloqué mais aussi pointé du
doigt de l'autre côté de ce fossé si je
dirais donc si je puis dire dans la
communauté internationale très
clairement en europe via la france au
cas avec le président français manuel
macro auquel à mi mots eh bien on
reproche ici de continuer cette
médiation en gros tout simplement de
continuer de parler à vladimir poutine
alors on voudrait cesser toute forme de
médiation toute forme de discussion avec
quelqu'un qui a vécu ici comme étant un
tyran un homme qui veut l'extermination
de l'ukraine donc c'est ça je dirais en
réponse à votre question c'est un entre
deux une croisée des chemins qui n'était
résolument pas ce à quoi on pouvait
s'attendre au delà de la guerre qui a
surpris tout le monde mais également
cette guerre éclair cette opération
spéciale militaire qui aurait dû durer
quelques jours pour conquérir kiev ça
déjà le scénario n'est pas celui-là mais
en tout cas il est extrêmement difficile
de prédire l'avenir il y à des pertes
colossales bien qu'on le disait il ya
une guerre informationnelle dont on ne
sait pas propagande contre-propagande
quels sont les vrais pertes mais on sait
qu'il ya des pertes très importantes
dans les deux camps actuellement dans le
dans le combat sans parler évidemment
des victimes civiles et des énormes
horreurs dont on a parlé qui sont en
train de se de se passer mais c'est
certainement lors d'un bilan l'heure où
il va falloir face à l'histoire face à
la manière dont on va retenir c'est
fantastique épopée militaire qui est en
train de se jouer ici totalement inédite
dans cette partie du siècle et bien face
à l'histoire il va bien falloir décider
effectivement de quel côté on se range
en tout cas les ukrainiens ici jeu dire
veulent absolument que l'europe
rejoignent l'élan américain et essaye
d'en finir kita même allé dans une
tactique d'offensive et pourquoi pas
bien de repousser les russes or
d'ukraine merci à cyril séries en direct
de kiev avant de rebondir justement sur
le point de vue diplomatique
adrien des u17 guerre aujourd'hui est ce
qu'elle se joue véritablement dans le
donbass et est-ce qu'on est
effectivement une croisée des chemins
d'un point de vue militaire
ah oui actuellement les opérations se
concentrent dans le combat donc dans la
partie est de l'ukraine et le président
zine ce qui a formé une espèce de
l'appel à l'aide parce que effectivement
l'armée ukrainienne est en grand danger
d'encerclement dans la région de ses
skis et biéreau donesk et il ya une
percée qui est effectué par l'armée
russe au niveau de pop hasna ce qui
menace et au niveau du liman ce qui
menace vous prendre partie de l'armée
craignant d'être encerclés et
effectivement ce serait dans ce cas là
on peut une redite cette guerre de 2022
une redite de cette guerre de 2014 où la
mairie de l'armée ukrainienne s'était
dans un premier temps très bien très
bien comporté et ensuite dans un
deuxième temps avait dû reculer dans le
donbass et ensuite le front s'était
stabilisé mais il faudrait pas en avis
que l'ukraine non plus comme est une
deuxième erreur qui serait de vouloir à
tout prix vouloir reprendre le tour le
dombass et même la pluie mais comme le
dit n'est plus les plus faucon de kiev
parce qu'à ce moment-là il risquerait de
tout perdre à nouveau je pense qu'il
faudrait reprendre en fait le processus
qui a été initiée notamment par la
diplomatie française en normandie et
puis à minsk et c'est à dire d'un
règlement général de la question et
craignent haine entre les russes et les
ukrainiens avec les occidentaux bien sûr
exigeante genté est ce que vous voulez
justement réagir à ce que vient de dire
adrien de juin avec d'abord jusqu'au
qu'on comprenne bien est ce qu'on peut
penser qu'il pourrait y avoir une
contre-offensive ukrainienne aujourd'hui
dans don basse où on peut le penser
puisque l'armement occidentales et les
livres et c'est évidemment un des
facteurs absolument clé du sort de cette
guerre il est en train d'arriver suite
aux dernières décisions de notamment
washington d'augmenter encore le soutien
militaire donc oui on peut penser que
dans les semaines qui viennent au mois
de juin sera certainement important à la
fois dans le donbass probablement aussi
en mer noire selon ce que j'ai pu
entendre puisque la flotte de la mer
noire est un facteur important aussi
pour au sujet de l'enclavement de
l'ukraine donc on peut éventuellement
s'attendre à ce que l'ukraine les
ukrainiens tente aussi de porter la
bataille à fort des missiles reçu de
l'occident peut être en mer noire donc
ils peuvent gagner dans son bassin
contrairement à ce que ce cas l'air de
dire derrière des hommes mais je suis
plutôt en désaccord avec cette position
d'abord parce que effectivement là la
question clé c'est pas de dégâts
territoire dans le donbass poutine n'a
rien à faire la seule question c'est
contre les kiev soit physiquement soit
en installant un régime fantoche disons
ça c'est vraiment la question clé donc
les ukrainiens se disent que rester sur
un statu quo dans le donbass tôt ou tard
ça veut dire que la guerre reprendra
parce que l'objectif de poutine et du
kremlin hausse et au delà de monsieur
poutine à vrai dire c'est de repousser
de contrôle et kiev donc je pense pas
que les ukrainiens pour en accepterons
ce statu quo
jean maurice ripert vous êtes le diplôme
est de ce fait au large oui non
simplement moi j'ai été frappée du fait
que plusieurs reprises depuis trois mois
le président eugène ce qui a eu le
courage de dire moi je suis prêt à
négocier il l'a encore redit ce matin
jour oui je suis disponible pour parler
avec monsieur poutine quand il veut il a
déjà dit qu'il renonce et août il avait
compris que le temps l'ukraine
n'adhérerait pas l'otan il a également
dit qu'il était prêt à discuter du
combat c'est là je rejoins ce qu'a dit
monsieur pas bien sûr ou pardon sur
minsk où quelque chose c'était pas
monsieur revenir sur les accords des
livres non de revenir un processus
politique qui d'ailleurs ne visez pas
l'entièreté du problème puisque ça ne
concernait pas l'annexion illégale de la
crimée enfin ça concernait le dombass
donc de mon point de vue monsieur hinse
qui a fait un geste considérable il a
pris des risques par rapport à ses
propres du train par rapport à la
population ukrainienne moi je ne crois
pas je suis pas un expert militaire mais
je pense que le front se stabilisera tôt
ou tard on voit bien le mouvement qui
est en train de se dessiner longue la
rivière donetsk avec les ukrainiens qui
remonte vers la frontière russo nord et
les russes qui descendent vers le sud
vers l'ouest dans le sud la situation
pourrait stabiliser ce que je pense
c'est que monsieur zemlinsky quand ils
reprochent entre eux en deux mots à
monsieur l'affront de négocier ça n'est
pas forcément de parler à vladimir
poutine c'est de vouloir éventuellement
parler au nom de l'ukraine et d'avoir
peur que ce ne soit pas lui et foncent
qu'il a raison monsieur hinse qui veut
fixer les termes de la négociation mais
j'ai entendu la vice première ministre
ukrainienne qui est passage à paris en
ce moment dire ce matin nous avons
besoin que la france parce qu'elle est
la france et parce qu'elle est la
présidence actuelle de l'union
européenne s'implique dans une
négociation à emmen et aux conditions
des maîtres indiens à kiev espère
je trouve que on est très très je
comprends tout à fait d'abord on admire
la résistance des ukrainiens et on
comprend tout à fait la souffrance et
d'ukrainiens quand la france livre des
armes quand la france probablement
procure du renseignement même si c'est
quelque chose qu'on apprendra que bien
plus tard ou jamais
et quand le président de la république
maintient un lien pour parler de même
avec un tyran se sont pas des actions
contradictoires c'est la même action
l'autre discours étant celui de
washington et du pentagone que les
ukrainiens ferait désormais la guerre
contre les russes par procuration pour
notre compte et ça c'est certainement ce
qu'il faut éviter et je trouve que la
france garde raison dans cette affaire
et que c'est vital y compris pour
l'avenir des ukrainiens et l'avenir même
si voleurs d'iberia qui demande à
emmanuel macron de venir à kiev depuis
un moment ils lui demandent au président
français oui boris johnson je crois y
est allé ou deux enseignes état est ce
que ça raconte des personnalités que ça
a changé grand chose
je pense que on est dans la garde a
plutôt des images
je peux pense que la france contribue
beaucoup quand même à la résistance
ukrainienne encore une fois il faut pas
le diminuer alors puisque vous parliez
des états unis on va écouter henry
kissinger qui était à davos et enfin par
en visioconférence bien sûr et il a
évoqué ce conflit bien sûr on les écoute
nous espérons que les ukrainiens
égaleront l'héroïsme dont ils ont fait
preuve avec sagesse durant la guerre
jean maurice ripert lui parle d'un statu
quo status quo non mais c'est vrai ça la
sortie de crise vers la sortie
diplomatique évidemment comme tous les
diplomates et beaucoup de monde beaucoup
de respect pour monsieur keating un set
aux ukrainiens de décider de leur avenir
sinon nous nous comportons comme les
russes qui entendent décider de l'avenir
de l'ukraine sans les ukrainiens voir
contre les ukrainiens
donc il faut écouter zielinski il veut
négocier à ses conditions et c'est à ces
conditions que à mon avis le président
macron devrait finir par aller à kiev
tôt toutain et de la même façon que
l'union européenne devrait selon moi je
n'engage que moi accorder le statut de
candidat à l'ukraine ce que la
vice-première ministre a de nouveau
demandé candidate à l'union européenne
même si les négociations prennent dix
ans il faut traduire notre solidarité
maintenant est justement montrer que
nous faisons le contraire des russes
c'est à dire que nous reconnaissons
l'existence d'une ukraine libre
souveraine et démocrate les hells qui
avait insisté sur le fait que s'il
devait y avoir des cd des concessions
territoriales ce qu'il a fait très tôt
d'ailleurs il ne ferait en le faisant
sanctionner par des référendums de la
population donc il a pensé tout de même
déjà il a parlé de concessions
territoriales éventuelle dans le donbass
l'ambassade a raison ça a été fait très
tôt vers la fin mars entre accepté d'en
discuter dans le discuter dépendra de la
réalité du terrain évidemment et puis
ensuite d'obtenir des garanties
sécuritaires données notamment par les
occidentaux il s'agit pas de simplement
d'avoir un cessez le feu d'ailleurs
comment dire
as tu es tu secoues sur le terrain mais
il faut ensuite qu'ils soient garantis
pour ça ne recommence pas précisément
alors justement on va écouter maintenant
le ministre de la défense russe qui
s'est exprimé aujourd'hui on va voir
justement en l'écoutant s'il y a une
issue diplomatique possible
nous continuons l'opération militaire
spéciale jusqu'à la réalisation de tous
les objectifs peu importe les normes
aide occidentale au régime de kiev et la
pression sans précédent des sanctions
adrien désormais bien entendu l'un donc
un choïgou on continue cette opération
militaire spéciale donc pour le moment
on n'a pas du tout l'impression que les
russes accepte quelques négociations que
ce soit
non je pense pour les russes c'est
encore trop tôt pour pour négocier ils
veulent absolument remporter la totalité
du donbass donc à partir de ce moment là
ils négocieront mais pour l'instant
pourrait pas sortir de cette guerre du
avec le satisfait si je puis dire tant
qu'ils n'auront pas rentrer dedans basse
en tout cas c'est l'avis de shingo qui
représente l'ailé la plus dure de
du régime de moutier voilà donc s'il
remporte le dombass est-ce qu'ils vont
s'arrêter là c'est comme la question moi
je peux je pense que c'est leur intérêt
est-ce qu'ils vont le faire et ce qu'ils
auront la sagesse de s'arrêter je ne
sais pas mais en tout cas c'est leur
intérêt il sortirait j'allais dire la
tête haute de ce 2 mars si je puis dire
de ceux de ce conflit s'il avait
remporté le combat ce qui quand même est
assez probable d'ici quelques mois alors
ça on va voir parce que régis jantes et
lui parle d'une contre-offensive
ukrainienne est ce que finalement c'est
les russes effectivement font tomber le
dombass est-ce qu'ils vont s'arrêter là
en résulter c'est vraiment le terrain
qui est qui et qui décidera ça dépend de
l'ampleur des livraisons d'armes de
l'occident à l'ukraine et donc de sa
capacité à résister c'est presque assez
mécanique c'est presque mesurable si
j'ose dire mais mais l'intention non
certainement pas et le problème est
beaucoup plus profond je vis en géorgie
par exemple si vous prenez la question
du séparatisme qu'on connaît bien depuis
30 ans maintenant avec l'abkhazie et
l'ossétie du sud dont on parle souvent
ici de quoi est-il question c'était
avant et même la question de l'otan
c'était bien avant c'était avant
monsieur poutine on espère que la
question va au delà de ces questions
stratégiques c'est aussi il en va pour
la russie de sa puissance du contrôle de
son ce qu'il appelle son étranger proche
est effectivement d'abord je crois d'une
projection que sa puissance
je ne pense pas qu'ils s'arrêteront dans
basse le dombass n'a aucun intérêt
stratégique
économique encore moins ce sont des des
1200 tout est détruit aujourd'hui et
même avant par exemple le potentiel
minier du dans basse était très faible
c'était une économie complètement
subventionnite un fardeau à vrai dire
donc la question n'est pas du tout dans
le combat ce donc la guerre sera longue
tout et tout est possible on voit par
exemple dans l'est dans les talk-shows
russe en ce moment d d d d experts enfin
les talk-shows complètement sous
contrôle wiki ou des élections beaucoup
et ce en france voilà exactement la
bande qu'il représailles on voit des
experts ni à expliquer que tout va mal
qu'on va perdre qu'on est mal organisé
est ce que ça veut dire qu'on est en
train de préparer le terrain par exemple
pour après une éventuelle conquête d'une
partie du dombass dire on s'arrête là
nous avons obtenu objectif c'est pas
impossible non plus mais c'est vraiment
indécis je crois c'est jean françois
collet mais le problème c'est que depuis
faible 24 février 2022 tous les calculs
qu'on pourrait faire d'intérêts
stratégiques y compris en place des
russes en se mettant à leur place je
conviens la réflexion d'adriano siens
mais tous ces calculs sont des trompes
et on a véritablement le sentiment qu'on
est plus dans une forme de rationalité
là et que d'ailleurs c'est comme ça que
poutine présente sa guerre et 10 est une
question existentielle pour nous le
message que reprend le patriarche kirill
qui prêche la croisade
c'est à dire que en fait le discours est
inversé il est en train de détruire le
crâne mais c'est lui qui menacées
d'extinction et que don basse ou pas de
toute façon il est clair qu'il veut
laisser derrière lui s'il n'a pas
l'ukraine pour lui il veut laisser
derrière lui une ukraine en ruine totale
et il a comme de commencer fortement à
le faire donc on efface quand même à une
perspective qu'on pourrait qualifier de
nihiliste au sens de rien de la logique
du rien c'est tout ou rien ça c'est ça
le danger de cette guerre et samassa
père juste a ajouté je suis d'accord a
ajouté que en effet dans l'optique de
vladimir poutine qui a une forme de
rationalité boris cyrulnik disait la
nationalité de son délire et je pense
que c'est parfois est exact son délire
c'est de reconstituer l'urss de joseph
c'est toujours le cas trois mois après
et donc la nasa qui je suis d'accord
avec le fait que le problème du donbass
il perd le problème de l'ukraine où il
perd c'est que c'est un mauvais exemple
pour la géorgie vous savez qu'au
kazakhstan au kirghizistan et en
ouzbékistan il n'y a pas eu de défilé
militaire le 9 mai était ce un geste
incroyable de de défiance vis-à-vis de
moscou aujourd'hui un diplomate le
premier diplomate de haut rang a fait
défection à genève en disant j'ai honte
pour mon pays c'est contre tout cela que
vladimir poutine et entraîné j'aime bien
votre expression dans une spirale le
nihiliste spirale mais l'histoire face à
lui est justement l'autre surprise est
même ces trois mois il faut tout de même
y revenir c'est cette espèce de réveil
de l'otan l'otan qui était
qui et en mort cérébrale comme le disait
emmanuel macron effectivement on a vu se
réveille puisqu'on a vu deux pays dont
l'identité était la neutralité la
finlande et la suède demander l'adhésion
de l'otan jean françois colosimo là je
parle à l'historien si on va un petit
peu plus loin est ce que ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui on va se retrouver pour
la sécurité en europe avec un autant qui
sera à la frontière de la russie est ce
que ça veut dire que l'europe la paix
qu'elle a pu connaître la paix qu'il y
ait les objectifs de croissance
économique les impératifs de sécurité
nationale est ce qu'on peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui c'est terminé cette
période s'est terminée cette époque on
veut la restaurer c'est clair ce qui a
c'est que voyez là encore inversion
entre les buts et les résultats c'est
que un des buts affichés de poutine
s'était de prévenir l'installation de
missiles sur les 1500 km le missile de
l'otan sur les 1500 km de frontière
commune entre l'ukraine et l'otan il va
se retrouver avec 1700 km avec la
finlande s'il continue comme ça en fait
le problème que nous avons nous tout de
même européen il faut le dire c'est que
nous voyons le grand retour de
l'amérique au coeur de l'europe et nous
voyons que cette amérique c'est elle qui
prend en charge notre sécurité au point
d'ailleurs que noyon show spectaculaire
l'allemagne réarmer 1 qui franchit le
tabou de 1945 mais l'allemagne ne va pas
collaborer avec la france pour donner un
armement europe 1 elle va acheter des
armements américains et est de ce point
ça veut dire victoire oui dire quand
même que le commandement dernier lui
revient à qui détient des technologies
faut du temps et donc projet européen et
donc de ce point de vue là il ya quand
même une alarme ou une alerte très forte
sur notre propre capacité a malgré tout
assuré notre sécurité la suède et la
finlande sont pas candidates à une
alliance de défense européenne elles
sont candidates à l'alliance atlantique
ce qu'elles n'existent pas encore me
semble utile déguste on en parle plus de
recul excusez moi mais ce moment c'est
compliqué que cette opération maintien
de la paix par exemple des nations unies
les suédois et les finlandais les forces
suédoises et finlandaises se bat avec
les forces européennes mais là elles
veulent adhérer à l'otan oui je pense
qu'il faut pas opposer l'union
européenne et l'otan l'union européenne
c'est un projet politique le temps c'est
une alliance militaire qu' il feint dix
ans pour construire la défense
européenne qui balbutie donc vous vous y
croyez j'en remercie il faut dix ans et
pendant ces dix ans là il n'est pas
anormal que les chances équipe là où ils
peuvent vous là il va juste pour dire
vous avez monsieur erdogan qui est le
deuxième qui a la deuxième armée en
nombre de l'otan qui pose ses conditions
à savoir que la suède de la finlande
vous savez les autres nations qui sont
concernés mais à travers son art session
de kurdes bien sûr c'est ce que je vous
dis il demande à suez daf afin langue de
refuser le droit des idées à des kurdes
militants verts gagnera pas et il ne
gagnera pas mais voyez bien que l'otan
et l'europe c'est pas
d'accord
justement rien de ce qu'on est passé à
une autre phase aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on
passe dans une autre époque cette europe
de paix qu'on connaissait avec où il y
avait effectivement de la croissance
économique on allait finalement
croissance économique et stabilité
sécurité en fait est-ce que s'est
terminée cette période avec justement un
autant qui va être beaucoup plus présent
avec une europe qui n'est pas encore une
europe militaires et avec finalement
aujourd'hui cet ennemi russe parce que
c'est comme ça finalement qu'il définit
cette nouvelle architecture européenne
oui effectivement
la période de l'après guerre froide est
terminée et on revient justement cette
période assez content finalement de là
tout début de la première guerre froide
où on avait un bloc russo chinois très
compacte face à un bloc occidental très
compact et ensuite des années après à
partir des années 60 on a eu un dégel on
a eu un jeu international qui s'est un
peu fluidifier là on revient finalement
au tout début de la guerre froide avec
des bloc très compact très opposées sino
russes et occidentaux et un tiers monde
enfin qui n'est plus un tir en le
maintenant mais ils ont un troisième
camp qui est un peu plus notre avec
l'inde le brésil l'afrique qui pour
l'instant proposition d'entre 2 et n'ose
pas s'engager avec nez à nez avec
l'autre vas-y santé vous pouvez vous
voulez réagir je voulais juste souligner
un point effectivement on peut pas
exclure je crois à ce stade que la
russie puisse armand données qui peuvent
venir assez tôt s'en prendre directement
à l'occident par la pologne et la
prochaine question donc il ya quand même
un risque de troisième guerre mondiale
encore tout cela on n'écarte personne ne
les cartes parce que un des grands
enjeux c'est aussi le type de
gouvernance qui va présider au monde on
a une alliant pas une alliance mais un
rapprochement très fort entre la chine
vous souteniez tout à l'heure et la
russie on sent qu'il ya un combat pour
essayer de faire que ce que c'est que
ces pays puissent imposer leur type de
gouvernance au monde sont très dérangés
par par le fait qu'ils aient des
démocraties aussi imparfaite soit elle
est donc c'est aussi ça un d un des
enjeux je crois de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui sur la scène sur la scène
globale jean maurice ripert d'accord sur
le fait que les dix ans qui viennent
seront marqués par ce combat si je puis
dire entre les dictatures et les pays
démocratiques ça me paraît clair je ne
crois pas une seconde la ligue et en
europe il s'est terminé là
je ne crois pas du tout je crois qu'il
faut rester optimiste mais je crois
qu'on ne peut rien exclure compte tenu
du comportement nihiliste encore une
fois voire délirants du président
poutine on ne peut pas
va exclure qu'il arrive en transnistrie
aux frontières de la moldavie donc de
l'europe on ne peut pas exclure des
choses on a vu des avions russes survolé
la suède on a vu des sous-marins russes
rentrer dans les ports finlandais ou le
contraire je ne sais plus très bien donc
rien n'est à exclure mais je ne crois je
crois pas qu'il faille caricaturé en
disant que l'europe est soudain devenu
faible parce que les américains sont
devenus forts ce serait quand même un
paradoxe incroyable alors que nous
venons d'expliquer que pendante depuis
trois mois les russes ont plutôt perdu
la guerre que gagner on a plus le temps
me 31 ans vainqueur de la guerre de
crimée de la moitié du xixème siècle a
eu lieu très exactement sur ces régions
là n'est ce pas et c'était une guerre
mondiale entre guillemets on va regarder
on va terminer sur cette touche
optimiste merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous à jean françois
collet simon versé à vous jean maurice
ripert merci régis jantes et merci à
vous adrien de juin vous étiez avec nous
donc par skype de rouen et puis merci à
cyril payen cyril payen qui est avec
nous et qui est toujours à kiev merci
cyril merci à vous tous dehors suivi
vous restez avec nous sur france 24